you'd watch it I think everyone would be
really really sad with the product that
you get you got this doughy Mark
Zuckerberg this nerd walking out trying
to make a serious face scareless Elon
Musk walking out he's a robot for all we
know but still has tits very strange I
like Elon I don't like Zuckerberg Zucker
can kiss his ass you know how tired
they're gonna get after two minutes in
the first round then is it a full card
do you toss them on a major pay-per-view
UFC you toss them on an Izzy card who's
gonna headline there is Izzy the
headline into the co-main event this has
to be the headliner regardless you put
on ESPN I guess it's just regular UFC
pay-per-view but it'd be like that's
just one fight no no of course they'll
build the card discuss this will be
there